Let's recap the 2 systems of the Autonomic Nervous System. The Parasympathetic
and the Sympathetic. Remember Parasympathetic is when we're normally resting.
This results in things such as constricted pupils. It also constricts the
bronchi. It also results in slowed heart rate, and finally allows us to digest.
However, when something happens that is arousing, frightening or stressful. The
Parasympathetic Nervous System turns off, and the Sympathetic Nervous System
turns on. Here, we're going to see an opposite effect of what happens in the
Parasympathetic. So, for example, here we'll have dilated pupils. We'll also
see that the bronchi will relax. When the bronchi is relaxed, it allows for
increased air intake. So we have more oxygen for our muscles. Also we'll see
that we'll have an increased heart rate. Again, this allows for our fighting or
our fleeing. Finally, we'll also see that the Sympathetic Nervous System will
inhibit digestion. We don't need to worry about digesting our food when we need
to run away from a dangerous situation.